au premier jour de l'été fête de la
musique c'est le dixième anniversaire de
la manifestation même si cette année la
météo n'était pas tout à fait au
rendez-vous concert donc à travers toute
la france les spectacles parfois très
organisés ou totalement improvisée
thierry stampfler nous propose une
compil des meilleures images tournées
par nos stations régionales et aussi à
partie
m
21 juin 91 paris sous la pluie comme
l'année dernière
il y a les vedettes confirmées les
musiciens professionnels et puis tous
les autres le préféré d'un soir
a toulouse la musique bien sûr mais
aussi le soleil bande de petits veinards
poitiers la chapelle royale dirigée par
philippe herreweghe dans la superbe
salle des pas perdus du palais de
justice quelques instantanés d'une fête
par essence insaisissable car multiplier
à l'infini
et
voilà nous allons maintenant rejoindre
en direct au ministère de la culture à
paris michèle vial avec je crois à ses
côtés jack lang pour un premier bilan de
cette fête de la musique 91 michel est
ce que vous n'avez pas tout de même le
sentiment que cette fête qui a donc
maintenant 10 ans est un petit peu
institutionnalisée
embourgeoisé qu'elle a perdu un peu sa
spontanéité
écoutez très franchement je vous avoue
que je n'ai pas entendu d'autres
questions comme vous le pensez on ya
énormément brouillard nougali sandler
qui sont un de jouer tout à l'heure il y
aura mory kanté mais aux congés quand je
me demande si ça c'est la vitrine c'est
les stars de la musique internationale
mais le plus important c'est pas le
petit village la manifestation en plus
petits villages de france c'est vrai
vous avez raison
aux images n'ont fait apparaître un
instant
h comptabilité partout à travers
des villages des banlieues c'est après
midi par exemple
le président
les orchestres des musiciens isolé
succès de partout
ap vienne que jamais des gens répétaient
fait qu'entamer
original immédiat
le goût de la musique c'est un don c'est
un an qui peut s'enseigner qui peut
s'améliorer tient coi d'aujourd'hui
quand même parce que les enseignants de
la musique qui sont un peu en colère un
peu en grève
enfin les enseignants de la belgique est
là
il en riant
j'attends
dernière question
vous êtes pour la chaîne musicale ya pas
de chaises musicales depuis la
disparition de tv6 en 1987 alors quand
ils voient qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup d
influence parce que vous avez beau dire
vous êtes ou à nice bat
pour constater
conseil de l'audiovisuel est totalement
indépendant d'esprit jeu
les clubs depuis
rageant la recréation du rejet musicale
et j'ai peu d'espoir est ce qu'on a
entendu un jour merci encore aux
réalités
merci messieurs pour terminer ce journal
deux dernières informations d'abord une